all right let's bring in the shadow Home
Secretary of 8 Coopers here with us this
morning good morning to you thank you
very much for being with us just pick up
on what's Happening said there what's
the home section you're going to do
about the situation down in Kent well I
think the custom needs a real overhaul
and of course we've got real problems
this morning you've got that awful
attack in Dover obviously the serious
overcrowding clearly a diphtheria
outbreak in the conditions at manston
we've also had the allegations about
cyber security threats as well and the
person who should be sitting here
answering your questions providing
reassurance that the home office has a
grip or be in Parliament giving a
statement to Parliament is the Home
Secretary suarezman and she's not doing
that because she's still unable to
answer questions about her own security
breaches so we need action from the
homeless on home office in all of these
areas and at the moment we're not seeing
it I mean do you expect to hear from her
this week are you going to be trying to
push to hear from home secretary at some
point I think she needs to this is her
job you know you've got the awful
reports that we've just been hearing and
a lot of that is because the home office
decision making system has collapsed
they've got huge long delays in the way
that they're taking decisions and it's
got much much worse over the last few
years so we need to have answers on that
we need to have also answers on a whole
series of other areas and also to find
out from the Home Secretary well how
many other security breaches has she
herself been involved in she's her job
to do this it's her job that Rishi sunak
said we should have integrity
professionalism and accountability we're
not getting any of those three things at
the moment from the Home Secretary
that's not good enough when such
important issues around Public Safety
and National Security are at stake I
should remain in posts do you think
kistama has already said that Rishi
sunak should replace her I mean he
reappointed her just six days after she
had breached the ministerial code
without any proper answers we understand
that this was against the advice of the
cabinet secretary and the cabinet office
we think that advice should be provided
to the intelligence and security
committee for them to be able to to
scrutinize as well and there's been
allegations about other security
breaches been involved in so I think we
need to know the answers on those two I
mean that's not the only part of
government that's got some security
issues we're thinking about this morning
as well of course over the weekend we
find that the list trusses phone was
hacked as well I mean do you think there
needs to be a re-education for ministers
and how exactly they should be looking
after the security of sensitive data
well you're right and you've got
allegations around obviously cyber
security attacks but also there's
questions about why this story was
either briefed or leaked right now as
well which also raises national security
questions and so you know and concern
raised from some you know former retired
senior security people about the home
office not just the home office actually
you know across the government ministers
not taking the right approach to some of
these security issues you know these
guys are not novices they've been in
senior cabinet positions for a long time
was the Attorney General before she
became Home Secretary and so they ought
to know what the rules are they ought to
know what the appropriate way is to
handle these security issues and that's
why this feels so irresponsible it feels
like this is not taking National
Security seriously but also that the
deal even to get through abrahman in
post was really a political deal rather
than in the interest of the country
let's just return it again a little bit
to the immigration piece what is what is
the answer to this situation 38 000
people come over here uh this year a
thousand Crossing uh yesterday all the
labor party be doing to try and deal
with the number of people arriving so we
need action in a series of areas first
of all there must be much stronger
action on the criminal gangs that have
proliferated in the channel that are
putting lives at risk just in the last
couple of years we have seen this huge
increase in the number of criminal gangs
that they've effectively created a
multi-million pound industry a criminal
industry in putting people's lives at
risk and exploiting those who are
vulnerable so we want to to see a new
unit in the National Crime agency with
hundreds of specialist officers to work
with europol to work with the French
authorities on cracking down on those
criminal gangs and we would fund it
frankly by stopping the unworkable
unethical Rwanda plan which the
government's not spent another 20
million on just in the last few months
on a program that the Home Secretary
herself is failing so we need to do that
need a new agreement with France on
preventing boats Crossing and also
having a replacement for the previous
Dublin agreement but we also need an
overhaul of the Asylum system in the UK
they've added delays you've got 96
percent of the people who arrived by
boat last year so over a year ago
haven't had their claims decided that
means refugees aren't getting the
support they need and those who are not
refugees are not being returned and that
has substantially deteriorated on the
government's watch so taking money from
one policy and putting into a specialist
unit what about capacity what about for
them people are here who have been being
housed in situations describes
intolerably inhumane way as you write
your diphtheria and MRSA has been found
yeah and that's why they've got to take
far more decisions so we've still got 12
000 Afghan refugees for example who are
still in hotels because the government
hasn't sorted their situation out and
that they arrived last August so that's
just a terrible letdown of people again
who are vulnerable and fled persecution
and then ministers have added a three to
six month delay and added bureaucracy
into the Asylum decision making process
well of course that means you've then
got more people waiting in Asylum
accommodation where would you put them
this is the thing where well if you make
dinner to decide their claims because
then for those who are refugees
literally they can then work they can
then get on with their lives they can
get the support that they need if you've
made the decision if they're not
refugees they of course need to be
returned so it's that failure to make
decisions which means we've now got so
many more people waiting in Asylum
accommodation who are waiting for
decisions to be made and that's why you
then also end up with this overcrowding
at manston because there isn't anywhere
to move people to so at the heart of
this is the conservatives failure to
actually make the system work to just
take basic decisions in a fair and
sensible way and also to fail to work
with France on how you prevent the
dangerous Boat Crossings in the first
place does the labor party have a policy
on the numbers of people that he thinks
will be acceptable to be coming to the
country per year do you mean refugees or
do you mean the overall the overall so
so we think that you should have this
points-based system where you look at
different kinds of immigration rather
than having the kind of targets where
there's a bit of a row going on at the
moment in the government between some
parts of the government who seem to want
a net migration Target which goes back
to the old Cameron one which didn't work
of much a lower Target others who seem
to want actually a much higher overall
Target because they think it will
improve growth we don't think either of
those approaches are right we think you
should instead look at what the areas
we've got shortages for example around
Health and Social care where we need the
Health and Social care Visa but where we
should also be linking that to training
so we train far more doctors and nurses
and labors set out a plan to increase
those training places so that we don't
need to always have so much overseas
recruitment people coming from abroad to
work in our NHS have been a godsend to
our NHS and have been make what made it
possible to keep our NHS going and
that's going to continue to be important
but we also need to make sure there is
more training here refugees and Zone
Seekers how many
from refugees and Asylum Seekers we have
to do our bit alongside other countries
so we have to respond to the crisis that
have nobody could have imagined the
crisis in Ukraine for example and we saw
people from across the country want to
help to to offer up their homes to
welcome families from Ukraine who have
been forced out by Putin's illegal war
and we also had in Afghanistan that the
terrible uh you know crisis as a result
of the Taliban returning in Afghanistan
so I think with the issue of refugees we
have to respond to the crises that
happen and we have to do our bit
alongside other countries so there
should be you know cooperation
International cooperation in place but
we've always done our bit to help those
fleeing persecution I think we always
will as a country
Cooper thank you